how proud are your girls of you and vice  versa it's really cool you know when  they they know about the honest company  and they asked when they spend the night  at people's house like it that'd be  honest and there's a chinese their  shampoo like they're aware of it Haven  at school thinks I invented hand  sanitizer I didn't visit you just right  yeah but you know it's cool that they  can see their mom sort of wear many  different hats I am a mom to them at  home and they don't like it when I break  out in song and dance it embarrasses  them which i think is really good but  you know at work they get to see me play  a different role they saw the different  you know versions of the office we had a  tiny little office and then we've gone  bigger and bigger and or more employees  and so they've seen that so it's really  cool to show them that  you